bonjour estelle alors les premiers
manifestants sont déjà arrivés oui tout
à fait venir alléger les jeunes ont
répondu présent à ce rassemblement dont
le rendez-vous a donc été donnée ici
devant le conseil d'état alors vous
allez le voir sur ces images de robin
dubois ils sont plusieurs
ils sont nombreux à arborer un parapluie
multicolores en soutien à moon
cette manifestante qui a été interpellé
dans la manifestation samedi dernier
elle a été accusée est bien de a
déclenché les violences
avec son parapluie du côté des
revendications de ce rassemblement et
bien ils sont à diverses il ya bien sûr
un refus de la loi sécurité globale mais
aussi à des revendications qui ont fait
le mouvement un dg les jaunes à ses
débuts comme par exemple peu plus de
justice sociale je vous propose de les
écouter et voir la même chose de plus
belle alors qu'ils sont deux heures pile
doit pas l'être
on attend point chez monsieur max qui
nous a dit
bien qu'il ya des gens ont fait ce cours
et rien ne change donc aujourd'hui on
attend que les joueurs qui nous donne
prière pour demander mais tant qu il
donnera pensant toujours là pour les
embêter
tant qu'on aura un pouvoir qui ne sera
pas légitime et représentatifs de la
majorité de la population
je voudrais tu mets ça veut dire merde à
mâcon mais si je suis fait remarquer la
semaine dernière avec mon égard pendant
que le partage parce que je chante et on
est là on est là même si mac on ne veut
pas tout ça mais je continuerai est au
contraire plus il y aura une réflexion
qu'on fait si les jaunes plus sereine
utile et on est là contre la loi ce qui
aurait été plus bas l'article 24 ans
n'entre pas dans sa totalité
de toute façon la coupe est pleine je
crois que les français commencent à
s'éveiller la crise sanitaire
une mascarade en ce sens qu'elle permet
de détruire
tous les fondamentaux
la constitution nos quais d art et de
circuler de vivre de sourire voilà pour
les revendications annie va alors
initialement c'est gilet jaune avait
imprévue à de déréguler à dans les rues
de la capitale avec ce qu'ils appellent
une marche des pouvoirs c'est à dire
qu'il entendait passer par différents
lieux symboliques comme par exemple le
sénat l assemblée nationale ou encore
matignon et la préfecture de police a
retoqué à ce parcours en raison
notamment d'un risque de trouble à
l'ordre public
mais la préfecture a autorisé les a
autorisés à des bandits a déambulé
jusqu'au pont des arts alors certains
ici à nous ont dit qu'ils entendaient à
rester à rassembler ici dans un
rassemblement à statique d'autres soit
tout de même des anglais dans les rues
de la capitale
voilà déroulée cette manifestation est
encore un peu flou voilà ce que ce que
je peux vous iranien